j'aurais pu faire un effort sur l'avenue
quand même tout le monde surtout pour
nous regarder à part ça c'est moi qui
suis bizarre si tu penses que je vais
revêtir ses vêtements ridicule tue
toujours le pilote en recto tonnes
passion jet et laisse moi parler au
coeur jeu direct et vasseur folle
[Musique]
aulas tavernier c'est vrai moi une part
nous sommes à la recherche d'une pirate
et on nous a dit qu'elle se trouvait ici
c'est ma soeur folle en fait oui astrid
et en bas tu es que quand elle aura fini
de mon stock on l'appelle à la plonge
merci l'ami braquo dormi à l'esprit
comme titi ont tous consommé pas surtout
yoko bonjour astrid bard et vous ai
écoutés aînés bien je discute et je suis
sérieuse barre et je veux pas de
problèmes
et vous vous avez des galas problème
nous avons juste quelques questions à te
poser des sourds de la romaine à rentrer
chez la prof veut pas être mêlée à vos
histoires ce moyen plus écoute nous
sommes toutes les trois coincés hors de
notre époque sans savoir pourquoi je me
souviens même plus comment j'ai atterri
ici
et visiblement en croire ta réaction
c'est plus que nous alors dis nous ce
que tu sais te plaît et ensuite promis
un disparu
vous avez un dossier de culot de venir
ici vous savez combien d'enchaînements
boisredon et vous vous promenez comme ça
à l'air libre sans faire attention je
vais vous dire ce que je sais mais c'est
vraiment pour que vos conneries bouton
franchement ça me va on était content
déjà on est coincé ici parce que le
transfert a merdé
vous vous en doutiez le problème avec la
cyber historienne qui nous a contactés
c'est qu'elle ignorait qu'elle avait une
historienne parmi ses ancêtres
la prof et du coup ça fait capoter toute
l'opération
il ya des ancêtres qui sont retrouvés au
23ème siècle à d'autres chez la prof on
sait pas pourquoi
comment tu sais ça discutait avec les
autres tout ce que j'ai pu trouver donc
tu n'étais pas isolé loin de tout le
monde comme tu semble le prétendre
où sont les autres non
tout est encore en fuite comme ça et
puis je me casse je sais plus trop
attention cache-cache mais ça a été
super passé pour moi de te retrouver
je suis une pirate dont la barre qui
essayent de nous tuer les cyber
historiens non c'est trop pour retourner
à notre époque on perturbe le continuum
espace temps en étant ici et qu'on leur
serve plus à rien maintenant qu'on a vu
notre époque un témoignage sur la force
et m'ont visé mais par exemple twilight
tu peut alors être son époque terroir et
tout mais en sachant que la monarchie
prend enfin quelques siècles plus tard
et qu'un tas de choses sombres
bon bah ça des vraies farces et lanton
d'émaillage après gibet que ça justifie
nous traquer et monsieur aimé pour les
cyber historiens c'est le cas alors
autant se planquer ici et voir devrait
en faire autant
comment tout ça je sais surtout grâce à
un cyber historique j'ai chopé l'autre
ils avaient été envoyés pour me tuer où
elle table où est-ce qu'on peut
l'interroger plus maintenant doit avoir
commencé à être mangés par les vars et
d'eau fait beau à voir
je les fais parler avant le farman et
donc je sais tout ça est donc je suggère
de vous portez vous êtes clairement pas
de taille pour la faire face surtout toi
avec ta robe de six pieds donc
donc laissez moi me débrouiller avec ça
et fait discrète et non attends s'il ya
de la bagarre je veux en être
je tiens bien profiter du 21e siècle
tant que je suis là et sans risquer de
me faire tuer à chaque coin de rue si
possible pour ce que tu sors
quant à moi j'étais censé faire un
rapide tour au 23ème siècle rentrer chez
moi et me marier alors il est hors de
question que je reste ici à moisir si on
est les seuls d'ancêtres restantes de la
proche alors ce matin nous nous battrons
ensemble
je me suis acheté un téléphone ici
débrouillez vous pour retrouver en aussi
envoyé le numéro je vous contacterai si
jamais les jumeaux et en attendant vous
essayez de rien faire de stupide
ok que j'ai pas à regretter je vois pas
pourquoi tu dis ça
[Musique]